In the last video, where we
launched something at an angle,
we figured out the horizontal
and the vertical components
of that launched velocity.
And we used a vertical
component to figure out
how long that thing
is in the air.
And then we used that
time to figure out
how far it will travel, given
a constant horizontal velocity.
What I want to do
in this video is
to redo part of that problem.
And I want to redo
the part to figure out
how long this object
stays in the air.
And I'm going to do it in a
slightly more complicated way
than the way I did
in the last video,
but it's kind of a
more powerful way.
And we'll see that it's more
powerful in future videos.
So the last video, to figure
out how long it's in the air,
we said, look.
We're starting and stopping
at the same elevation.
Whatever our vertical
velocity is here upward,
we're going to have the
same magnitude of velocity,
but it's going to be downward.
We used that insight to figure
out the change in velocity,
and then we used that
change in velocity
and the constant acceleration
due to the force of gravity
on an object in free fall, to
figure out the time in the air.
And it was pretty
simple mathematically.
What we're going to do now
is, to derive a formula that's
useful in physics,
although, I like
to always derive
it from scratch.
And that's how we're going
to derive it over here.
And you've see me derive
this formula before.
But just to start off, we
need to remind ourselves
that the vertical velocity that
we calculated in the last video
was five meters per second.
And given that
vertical velocity,
let's figure out how long
this thing stays in the air.
So our vertical velocity, our
velocity in the y direction,
is five meters per second.
And also as a reminder,
our convention,
when we're dealing with
vectors in one dimension,
and this is essentially
in one dimension
now, since we know it's
in the y direction,
is positive means up,
negative means down,
when we're dealing with
the vertical direction.
When we're dealing with
the horizontal direction,
positive means to the right,
negative means to the left.
So just to make sure we
have those conventions down.
So how can we
figure out how long
this thing stays in the air?
So we can remind ourselves
that the displacement,
and everything we're
talking about now,
is, well, this
will actually apply
whether in any one dimension.
But the displacement is
equal to the average velocity
times our change in time.
Times the amount of
time that elapsed.
And what is our
average velocity?
Our average velocity is-- if we
assume constant acceleration--
it is our final velocity
plus our initial velocity.
Actually let me
write it this way,
it'll make it a
little bit cleaner.
It is our initial velocity
plus our final velocity divided
by 2.
So literally the arithmetic
mean of our initial
and final velocities.
And we're going to multiply
that times change in time.
Now, what is our final
velocity going to be?
Our final velocity--
I'll write it over here.
Our final velocity is the same
thing as your initial velocity,
plus acceleration,
your acceleration
times how much
time has passed by.
This right here is
your final velocity.
So let's substitute that back
into this, right over here,
and what do we get?
We get our initial velocity,
so our average velocity
is now our initial velocity
plus our final velocity.
The final velocity
is this over here.
So it's our initial velocity
plus the acceleration
times the amount of
time that passes by.
All of that divided
by-- let me do
that same color-- all
of that divided by 2.
And then all of
this is multiplied
by the amount of
time that passes by.
Once again, this is
our total displacement.
So this part right over here--
let me do it in magenta--
we have to vi's.
All right.
So that simplifies to two vi's.
2 times our initial velocities.
And so this expression right
here simplifies to two times vi
divided by 2 is our
initial velocity.
And then we have-- well,
I'll just do it all here.
And then I'll multiply it times
the time elapse after that.
Plus the acceleration
times time,
the acceleration times
the amount of time
that's passed by, divided by 2.
And all of this is multiplied
by the amount of time
that passes by.
And this is our
total displacement.
And we're almost done.
And if you have to take
a physics exam under time
pressure, it's not
ridiculous to not
have to rederive it every time.
But I want to emphasize it.
You should realize that these
formulas come from almost just
common, basic sense
principles, and you
should be able to derive them.
But it's good to memorize them
if you have a time pressure
exam.
So now if we multiply
this delta t,
you get the total
displacement is
equal to your initial velocity
times your change in time,
plus-- I'll do the same
color-- plus your acceleration
over 2 times-- you have a
delta t times a delta t.
Remember, delta just
means change in time.
This triangle just
So change in time
times change in time
is change in time squared.
And this expression right here,
this is in some physics books
or in some classes, they'll
just give you this formula.
But I wanted to just
show you that it's
derived from very,
very simple principles.
From just, displacement is
average velocity times time.
What is average velocity?
What is final velocity?
It's just initial velocity
plus acceleration times time.
And you'll get this
expression right over here.
So I did this to figure
out how much time we're
going to spend in the air.
So how do we do that for
this particular problem?
Well, we know our
initial velocity,
that's the launch of
the vertical component,
because we're dealing with just
the vertical component here.
We know our initial velocity.
We know the acceleration
due to gravity.
And in this situation,
we want to figure out
when the displacement
is going to be--
and this is going to be
a little bit unintuitive,
but hopefully it
makes sense-- when
the displacement
is going to be 0.
Because there's going to be two
times when the displacement is
going to be 0.
There's going to be the time
right when we launch it,
right at time 0 the
displacement is going to be 0.
Then this thing's going to be
launched and then come back
to the ground.
And then when it comes
back to the ground,
the displacement is
going to be at 0 again.
So if we set the displacement
to be equal to 0,
we should get two answers
to that, and one of them
should have a non-zero
time component.
One of them will probably
be 0, and the other one
will have a non-zero
time, and that's
the one that we should go for.
Because that's the
second time, that's
the time when we've
hit the ground.
So let's apply that.
So we have the
displacement is going
to be 0, so 0 is equal to--
our initial velocity is
5 meters per second upwards.
I won't write the units
just for the sake of space.
5 meters per second upwards
times change in time, plus,
what's our acceleration?
Well, our convention is if
somethings going downwards,
if the one dimensional vector is
going downwards, it's negative.
So the acceleration is negative
9.8 meters per second squared.
You divide that by 2.
So we get-- actually just
let me write it all out.
Actually let me
write it like this.
It's negative 9.8 meters
per second squared.
I'm not writing the units
here just for simplicity,
just so that we don't
take up too much space.
And then all of this
times delta t squared.
And lucky for us, this
one is pretty simple,
we don't have to resort to
factoring, or we will factor,
but we don't have to resort
to the quadratic formula
or anything like that to solve
this quadratic equation, right
over here.
We can factor out a delta t.
So we get 0 is equal to delta
t times 5 minus 9.8 over 4.2
is 4.9.
And if you factor out a delta
t out of delta t squared,
you're left with a delta t.
So there's two
solutions here, There's
two delta t's that
will give us 0.
Either this delta
t is equal to 0,
so either delta
t is equal to 0--
that's just our starting point.
So that's not the time
that we're interested in,
where no time has passed by.
Or all of this business
could be equal to 0.
If we have two things
when we take their product
that equal 0, that means
either one or both of them
are equal to 0.
So we have 5 minus 4.9
delta t is equal to 0.
We could add 4.9 delta t to
both sides of this equation.
And we will get 5 is
equal to 4.9 delta t.
And then we divide both sides
by 4.9 to get the elapsed time.
So delta t is equal
to, 5 divided by 4.9
is-- we're at the home
stretch-- 5 divided by 4.9
is equal to 1.02 seconds.
So it's equal to 1.02 seconds.
And so once again, we
got the same exact answer
we got in the last one, we
just used a different method.
And that's one of the really
fun things about physics
is as long as you're
doing logically
consistent correct
things, there's
many ways to often
get that answer,
but it should be
the same answer.
If it's not, you
probably did something
wrong in one of those
two ways of doing it.